Speaker 1: Major news from the MAGA riots. Stuart
Rhodes, the founder of the right wing Oath Keepers
Group, has been sentenced to 18 years in prison
for his role in seditious conspiracy surrounding
the January 6th MAGA riots. This is a serious
sentence. The NBC News report reads. The founder
of the far right Oath Keepers has been sentenced
to 18 years in federal prison in connection with
the January 6th attack on the Capitol following
his conviction on seditious conspiracy.
The sentence for Stuart Rhodes is the longest
imposed on a January six defendant to date in a
politically charged courtroom before sentencing.
Rhodes called himself a political prisoner and
said when he talked about regime change in a phone
call with supporters earlier this week, he meant
he hopes that Trump will win in 2024. The judge
disagreed and says, you, sir, present an ongoing
threat and apparel to this country and to the
republic and to the very fabric of this democracy.
Wow. So I want to say a couple of things about
this. One of the things I don't do, unlike the
right, which says lock this person up, lock that
person up, throw away the key death penalty,
all these different things. I have not once said
I want them to crush these rioters and throw him
in prison for life or whatever. What I have said
is we have evidence that crimes were committed,
so folks should be charged and then they
should go through the legal process. And if
they are convicted, they should be sentenced
fairly in according to sentencing guidelines
for the crimes for which they are
convicted. That's law and order.
And all of these right wingers who want to shout
that they are for law and order while they demand
Hillary be locked up and they demand that Biden
be locked up and Hunter Biden, all this stuff,
you're not actually for law and order if you want
to deny people due process. And so all along,
I have said there are very serious allegations
surrounding many of these Trump rioters. But I
want justice to be done. And that means that I'm
not going to go around demanding people be locked
up at all or for amounts of time that don't
correspond to the crimes they have committed.
Here we have a situation where Stewart Rhodes was
found guilty of seditious conspiracy. That's a
very serious crime. There are those who will say
that the mere prosecution of these individuals
is politically motivated. Are all these are the
judges. Remember, a lot of these judges are Trump
appointees. If you actually can demonstrate
that there was wrongdoing or mishandling of
these cases, do it. They all get their right
to appeal. But we are now seeing that these are
serious crimes which juries of these individuals,
peers have decided there is enough evidence to
convict. So now Stewart Rhodes is facing eight
facing. He's been sentenced to eight years. I
always forget whether there are any situations
with federal sentences where you get time off for
good behavior. Maybe he will serve close to that
full 18. Maybe he will not. This is a reminder,
hopefully, even though there have not been
consequences to the top level insiders like Trump.
And we'll see if there are any consequences.
This is a reminder that you might want to allow
peaceful transition of power to take place rather
than doing what these criminals and we can say now
that they are criminals have done. All right. So
we'll see if there are any longer sentences. But
to date, 18 years, the longest coming out of the
MAGA riots Monday, Memorial Day. Folks were off
on Monday for Memorial Day. But remember, we'll be
doing our one day membership special. Get notified
by getting on my newsletter at David Packman dot
com. The David Pacman Show is an audience meaning
you funded program. We depend on the support
of viewers and listeners whether you listen to
the podcast or watch us on YouTube or Tik-tok or
wherever the case may be to sign up for membership
at Join Pacman dot com. It's an incredible
thing you can do. So using the coupon code
24 starts now and we are really in the thick of
it as many of you now. You can also instead wait
until Monday. This Monday, Memorial Day. Get
on my newsletter at David Pacman dot com and
Monday you'll get an email telling you how to
sign up at an even more outrageous discount.